[Music]
hey that's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans checking in to say Happy
New Year we're here at hot ones we have
one resolution and one resolution only
and that is more sauce
so we're kicking off 2020 the only way
we know how and that is with our season
11
hot sauce reveal last season we brought
back sauces from some of our favorite
makers in the history of the show this
year though we're bringing some new
friends into the Ring of Fire along with
a globe-trotting range of spicy flavors
designed to keep our celebrity guests
sweating through the career spanning
deep dive interview that is the hot ones
experience so without wasting any more
of your time I can see a you're reading
ahead already leading off it's the
classic what more is there to say about
the classic it's just good clean family
fun and here at hot ones were all about
clean good family fun take for example
the Eric Andre Besson I'm gonna eat out
your camera operators you hear that boys
in the two spot please welcome to the
table Cantina Royale tamale Pekka this
sauce is made in Brooklyn by a chef from
Mexico and to quote hot ones alum Johnny
Knoxville it's muy delicioso with
tropical tamarind smoky chiles and a
kiss of sweetness it's great on chicken
or vegan ugh
into that sort of thing alright moving
on to the three spot we hop in the prop
plane and head to the South Pacific to
scoop up Fiji fire native bongo chili
hot sauce I can safely say that this is
the first sauce we've ever had on the
show that features bongo chili peppers
it's also the first sauce that we've
ever had on the show that features
Fijian turmeric and it's also the first
sauce that we've ever had on the show
that pays tribute to the Fijian fire
walkers come with me celebrity guests
fire walk with me down the hot ones
gauntlet don't be scared and then here
at number four what's that take two and
then here at number four what's that
it's double take salsa company's scotch
bonnet mustard
now spice Lords you already know how I
feel about a mustardy Caribbean hot
sauce
shout out to pirates lantern from season
six and just like that sauce this one
right here it has that bright scotch
bonnet heat and then the Tang eNOS of
the mustard to go right along with it
the perfect sauce for clearing the
sinuses right before some explain that
gram anecdotes and speaking of double
takes louis calientes is back in the
five spot and it's red I am excited to
announce los calientes Rojo a
supercharged remix of the original with
an extra handful of habaneros citrus and
spice to crank things up a bit this
sauce right here was the standout star
of our special release subscription box
last month and you know what we heard
your calls we saw your texts we read
your emails and it is time we hear you
time to bring los calientes Rojo up to
the big leagues it is back in the five
spot available February 6th February 6th
heat mist calm heat mist calm to order
just in time for the season 11 premiere
of hot ones all right things are heating
up we're moving on to the back half from
the shores of SoCal to Southeast Asia
number 6 brings us to seed Ranch hot
Thai green you smell that
lemongrass aromatic basil ginger
combined with lime juice it reminds you
of a delicious Thai curry you know what
else is in that bottle Carolina Reapers
and that reminds you that you're in the
back half of the season 11 lineup and
the kid gloves are off okay moving on to
number seven we take a trip to Ontario
this is pepper north Stargazer a
diabolical blend of ghost peppers Scotch
bonnets and jalapenos snapped into focus
by citrus Chipotle and a touch of maple
sweetness shout out to Canada
shout out to Matty Matheson shout out
world peace all right moving on down the
line up in the eighth spot it is the
longest-tenured hot sauce and hot ones
history ten straight seasons and
continuing it's Cal Ripken jr. like iron
man streak it is de bomb
beyond insanity de bomb is the sauce
that needs no introduction if you've
been watching us for any amount of time
if you're new here check out the
in comp video that we put out a couple
weeks ago Colin made it
shout out Colin Higgins dabomb forever
in the eighth spot or at least it still
is it still is it is still here baby
shout out Tom Brady alright moving on to
the 9 spot another thing you know if you
watch the show is that we like to save a
space on our gauntlet for our friends
down under and at number 9 its dingo
sauce cow's Widowmaker all you need to
know about this sauce is that it
features six super spicy strains packed
into one and designed to punch you right
in the mouth jab jab right hook left
hook uppercut haymaker Widowmaker all
right bringin up the caboose and then
letting it loose it's your fave in the
10th spot the last dab xxx
remove your caps for smokin ed curry
salute to pepper X and let's give a
special ovation to our season 11 hot
ones hot sauce lineup here it is in all
of its flaming glory you'll get to see
our new sauces in action during the hot
ones season 11 premiere February 6th
that's right we're back on the Internet
February 6th also premiering in February
hot ones the game show on truTV so a
huge month for us here at hot ones and
you know what it would all mean nothing
it all mean absolutely nothing without
you the fans who've now rocked with us
into the 11th season look at us
who would have thought not me we'll see
again February 6th thank you thank you
what is up spice Lords this is camera
guy bill here welcome to Bill's wind
tutorial there's one thing this Buffalo
boy knows how to do its eat a wing first
you're gonna wet your wing with some
sauce here for a little drizzle there Oh
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba and then
I like to do I I pull it apart and then
you get two wings so the price of one
you just move it up for more tutorials
on how to eat chicken wings smash that
subscribe the like button this is camera
guy bill here saying it's good to be
camera guy bill
[Music]
[Applause]
you